In this lesson, we're gonna take a look at material
functions and how to create one.
So let's get started.
So the material functions many will ask is exactly
what is it used for?
Why is it important?
Well, it allows you to embed materials
within materials, avoiding an unnecessary clutter.
So it allows you to encapsulize information
and functionality within a material set
that you can bring into a parent material.
It can be saved in packages and migrated as well
as reused across multiple materials.
So you can actually create them and expose them
to your library and to be able to call upon
the one that you've crafted.
It's really convenient and really great to work with.
And we have several different examples
and ones that you can use inside
of our material library.
What we're gonna do here is I'm gonna show you
how to create one from scratch into Unreal.
And we're going to be imitating a look and feel
of caustics of water bouncing off of water,
light bouncing off of water and then back onto a surface.
Let me show you on Unreal what our goals are.
As you can see here, a light is bouncing up
on the ceiling and we have an effect using a thing
called, if we scroll down,
it is called a light function material.
That's gonna be our end goal to be able to create this
and craft this and then plug that material in here.
And we're going to expose and make it so that it fits
in the category of a light function material
and will fit within this light.
I know it sounds complex, but it really isn't.
So let me walk you through this.
So let's go to our in class material folder.
We're gonna right click here
and we're gonna create a brand new material.
So I'm gonna click right here
and we're gonna call this one M underscore new caustics.
And this is going to be our parent material,
our goal and result.
We do wanna make a material function.
This is very important.
This is a very important part of the process
and we can't leave out because what's gonna happen
is we're gonna bring those material functions
into this final material.
So let's go and make a material function.
So I'm gonna right click here
and we're gonna go in here underneath our material.
And we're gonna go to our material function
and you'll find it here.
Don't get it confused with material function instance
or material instance.
These will have other places at other times.
And in this particular case,
we just need a material function.
And yes, you can make an instance of it,
but we're gonna be focusing on this.
And this also plays a different role.
Let's go and click on this material function.
There we go.
I'm gonna put MF on here and put underscore.
And we're gonna call this base water,
or you can even call it a wave effect.
So let's call it wave.
There we go, waves, works good enough.
Let's go ahead and open up this material.
Now, let me minimize it just for a second
cause I wanna point this,
I wanna make this clear
cause it's very important to consider this.
If you do get lost at any time,
feel free to click on the light
as you're following along
and go to that material on the details,
just scroll down a bit to under light function,
double click on it.
And in here, you can actually follow along
and see what I've done.
But to explain it a bit better,
let me show you what's going on.
This is the parent material,
which we're going to build things out.
Inside of here is the exposed material function.
And it's basically exposed to the library
so we can call it up.
So you can double click on that
and that will bring you into the material function.
Now don't let this intimidate you.
There's a lot going on here,
but a good amount of it is repetitive.
And I'm gonna walk you through this
so you can understand the concept.
So you can start exploring on your own
to make really good material functions.
And I'm telling you,
anytime you can, you can go to our library
and you can call up just by typing in MF
and you can see all the wonderful material functions
that we have for several different types of looks and feels.
And I do encourage you to go in here
and even reverse engineer and experiment with these.
So you can understand what's going on under the hood.
All right, so I just want to make that clear
so you don't get lost in any way.
Let's go and pull this one over
and we'll do the same thing with the parent.
We'll pull that out of the way.
So let's go ahead and get started.
Now, like usual, this happens a lot
when you make a material function, actually every time.
It's gonna give you an error.
So don't let that confuse you in any way.
All you need to do is right click here
and just say stop preview node.
I do want to mention,
and you'll notice it said shader model six.
Whenever you're working with Unreal,
you want to try to turn it on.
You want to turn on SM6 and double check your system
and see if it's on or not.
You can see mine is on.
This is helpful for many aspects of working with Lumen.
Okay, let's go to our full screen
and let's start building this out.
And I'm gonna point you in the right direction
on some of the textures that we're gonna need.
So don't worry about that.
Okay, so one of the things we want to do
is we want to determine what it is that we're making
and how it's going to be,
how we're going to access some of the features.
And the nice thing about this is you can do that
using a thing called a function input.
Function inputs are fantastic.
And you'll find this right here.
You'll notice in a pull down
that you can choose multiple things
for what you want to do for your function.
In our particular case, the first one,
we want to make sure that it's set to vector two
because we're really just working with a 2D texture
that we're gonna project on a wall.
Also make sure that you name it correctly.
So in this case, we'll call this wave coordinates.
We can just call it coordinates
and I spelled coordinates wrong.
We'll just put wave cord.
It is kind of long otherwise.
This will show up in the material function
when we drag it into the parent material.
So you can truncate them anytime you want.
We have this one set up,
but we need to make sure that Unreal knows our intentions
because this is great and all,
but Unreal doesn't know on what context
we want this to be displayed.
So I'm gonna give my finger the U key
and then I'm gonna call up a texture coordinate.
I'm gonna now grab the texture coordinates
and put it into my preview.
There you go.
That's working just great.
We can at any time also tell it to sort priority.
You also notice here we have used preview value
as default.
I like to turn these on.
Well, that's because I've been using Unreal for a while.
And in the past, if you didn't turn these on,
it wouldn't display correctly.
Wouldn't even show up to the party,
but I just get in the habit of turning them on.
Nowadays we have it
so that's not necessarily a determining factor,
whether it's gonna show up,
but I like to turn that on just for good measure.
All right, so we need to do a few more things.
So one of them is we need to make sure
that we have a 2D constant control
of the positioning of each of these waves.
So they're not all the same when you're working.
So we're gonna need a thing called a two constant vector.
So keep my finger on the two key and we'll left click.
And I'm gonna do that three times.
Now these numbers don't have to be perfect
nor do they have to be exactly what I have in here.
They can be whatever you want them to be
because shifting these is gonna change the look a bit.
So they do need to be off from each other
and not exactly the same.
So the first one we're just gonna set that to 0.4.
And then the second number in here,
we're gonna set that in the first two vector.
We're gonna set that to a 0.35.
Here we go.
The next one we will go
and let's shift this just a little bit.
And they can be a little bit farther from each other.
In this case, it's a 0.8.
My numbers that I have in here are a little bit longer.
And this little effect is a cool little effect
that we have in Paragon.
And I'm gonna go to Y and we'll do 0.14.
And we'll go to another one here, 0.651.
Doesn't have to have that extra.
It could just simply just be 65.
And then finally we do zero point
and these will be pretty close, 75.
And that works just great.
And we should be rock and rolling from that point.
Now what we want to do is go in here
and actually have it so they're connected.
The shifting of things is gonna help
with the wave coordinates.
So we're gonna be able,
we need to actually go in here and use an ad for these
so we can stack these appropriately.
So the ad and the multiply can be used to stack things,
but you gotta keep in mind
what kind of effect you're going for.
The ad in this case is gonna work good
and gonna make it so that if we do do a shift,
it's not going to scale any things.
And then we talked about that,
that the ad can keep things pretty linear
and the multiply is going to multiply things
and stretch and change the shape of things.
So we don't really wanna change the shape.
So I'm gonna give a few of the A key for ad
and do three of them.
Nothing needs to change really,
but we need to plug in these guys
into the B channel of each.
We're gonna grab the final execution of the X and Y,
which is the top white button,
or I should say execution string here.
And we're gonna put those all into the B.
Now we need a secondary channel in here.
It's based on our coordinates in here
and our coordinates are pretty default.
That's just one in one and that's fine.
Again, you can change these
once you decide what look you want.
I'm gonna pull the string down
to the each channel for each one of them.
Boom, look at that.
Pretty easy, pretty straightforward.
It's not that intimidating.
And at any time you can reroute these
and make it so they're not so noodly.
That does, it gets a little noodly here,
but I think we'll be okay.
I think we'll live.
All right, so we have here an opportunity here
where we need to actually maybe control the speed.
And the reason why is because we could leave it
and just have like some motion
and not have speed control,
but it's better to control the speed.
And to be able to do that,
we're gonna need another function input.
There you go, boom, function input.
We need to change this to a scalar parameter.
So scroll down, find, or actually he's at the top,
scroll down or scroll up,
get the scalar parameter going.
Fantastic.
That last number here for preview value,
we wanna make sure it shows up to the party all the time
so we're gonna keep that one on there.
You know, it's gonna turn red.
Now you'll find this a lot with Unreal
using some of these functions and even using a vector.
You'll notice a color vector will change color
based on positioning.
So the RGB will relate to almost an XYZ.
It's actually kind of cool.
So this one's gonna keep this one on and ready to go.
We're gonna go and add a multiply,
keep it for the M key and create a multiply.
And then I'm gonna create a thing called a time node.
This again, this acts like an input here.
If you control, control alt,
you'll see the time node is used to add
the passage of time to material.
So it's actually these little red functions here
are allowing me to be able to let Unreal know
my intentions as they bring in the data.
I'm gonna pull the string to the B channel
and I'm gonna pull this one into the A
and let's change its name to speed.
There we go.
And also turn on use preview value as default.
Awesome.
We're rocking and rolling so far.
Check your stuff to make sure you have what I have.
Fantastic.
All right, that's my really low budget
Sean Connery voice.
So let's go in here now
and we're gonna actually pull in some panner.
So keep your finger on the P key.
This is a hotkey for panner.
We did this in the very first texture class.
We made an animated texture, which is a lot of fun.
And we're gonna make sure here with these four,
cause we're gonna have one at the top
that's directly related to the coordinates here.
And we're gonna punch in our wave control vector
and I'm gonna close my stats.
So I have a little more real estate.
I'm gonna pull this into the coordinates here
for each one of them.
There we go.
I'm just doing this a bit,
probably a little bit early here.
We do wanna make sure that these guys are firing,
but we also need to make sure that they're firing off
from each other just a bit.
What that means is the first one,
we're gonna set this to a 0.1 across the board
in the X and the Y.
The second one, we can make negative 0.1
in the X and a negative 0.1 in the Y.
That works great.
But the third one, we kind of need to do a combo plate.
So we're gonna do a negative 0.1 on the X
and then a positive 0.1 on the Y.
And we're gonna flip that for the last one.
So we're gonna do a 0.1 positive on the X
and a negative 0.1 on the Y.
I'm gonna move this back a little bit, just a tad,
and let's go ahead and keep rocking.
All right, now we're gonna go in here
and control the texture information
because that's really important.
And again, we're going to be using our input texture
for this, function input, I should say.
And that's gonna, again, act as a gateway.
So we're creating functionality.
I'm gonna move this to the bottom.
I'm not gonna get them completely set up just yet,
but there are a couple of things I need to do.
One, let's change its name to texture.
If we want to, we can do sorting priority.
I'm gonna leave it at zero.
Unreal will just try to stack it
in the basically who came first.
With that in there,
you wanna make sure we have 2D in here.
So let's click on this
and make sure that we have a 2D input vector too.
And Unreal will let you know,
actually I should say texture, my bad.
It should be texture.
I always do that.
So let's go and grab that here.
There we go.
Function input texture 2D.
That's important.
Don't wanna miss that step.
So before we've finished that one,
let's actually connect these
because there really isn't,
Unreal doesn't know where this begins and ends
and we kinda need to tell him what's going on.
So let's go ahead and do that.
So in the ads here,
push them, all of them inside of our coordinates here.
Now, actually I messed up here.
I connected all my coordinates to all these.
He really just needs to go to the first one.
I should have followed my own advice
cause that's what I meant the first time.
I said it needs to go here
and then I connected all of them to here.
I was kind of in a flow, I apologize.
So let's disconnect all those
because now the ads need to go in there.
So the ad goes in the coordinate here.
The ad goes in the coordinate here.
And finally, we have one that goes in the coordinate here.
There we go for all three of these, perfect.
Now again, if you connected all these
and you're following along with what I was doing,
don't do that.
I was in a flow on a roll
and I just kept going with it.
We really just need this guy plugged in the top one.
And then all the other ads find their homes here.
I'll pulsate these so you can see what to do.
Sorry about that.
There we go, fantastic.
So now we need to go in here and plug the multiply
into this input speed into each one of the times.
So let's go and pull these strings
to each one of these times here.
Fantastic, look at that.
Smooth as butter, there we go.
Now we don't want to neglect the one we just made.
That's our texture 2D and we named it.
So make sure we also turn on the preview for that.
Now again, you don't necessarily have to do that
but I get in the habit of doing that
because well, I just want it to,
it's just a force to happen.
Just trying to keep things clean and unreal smart enough
that you don't necessarily have to do that all the time.
So we're good.
All right, so we're going to need some texture information
to go in here.
Let me show you how that works.
And again, if you want to,
you can change the sorting priority.
I'm going to set this one to one, that's fine.
So let me go and create a thing called a texture object.
Now people many times ask me,
Sean, what is a texture object versus a texture sample?
The texture object is a bare bones texture
with no RGB values in here.
He is pretty straight up, just texture information.
And you can see it here when you hit Control Alt
Unreal gives you a breakdown.
So let's go ahead and populate that
with a particular texture.
So we've provided for you a texture called T underscore base
and make sure we get the right one base underscore tile
because it has a nice tile for it, underscore normal.
There it is.
Let's grab that.
Now, if anytime you can't see what I'm doing,
like, you know, Sean, I can't get that texture.
What do you can do is actually go into your settings
and this goes for anything you maybe pull off
from the marketplace.
Just make sure that you look at your engine content.
You should be able to grab it.
If it's nested in a plugin, turn on your plugins.
So keep those things in mind.
I'm gonna pull the string over to the preview.
And then now what I wanna do is pull that
into the text slot here of some texture samples
that we're gonna make.
So the reason why we did this is
so that we can actually quickly change everything
all at one time.
If we want the texture to change,
all of them are gonna change.
And let me show you what I mean.
So now I'm gonna keep my finger on the T key
and create one, move it up, two, three, and four.
We have four texture samples.
Now we're not gonna load them with any specific texture.
We're going to use the one down here.
And this function input allows us to change them
all at one time if we need to,
which is ideal because we're doing caustics.
We're not doing anything super fancy.
We can always change this
if you did wanna do something super fancy.
So I'm gonna go and pull this texture into each one.
There we go, boom, excellent.
And then now we're going to pull in
and we're going to grab the panner that we created
and we're gonna move those into the UVs.
So move this into the UV, the first one,
the second one, the third one, and then the fourth one.
All those in there, excellent, excellent.
So what we can do now is let's move this back.
And oh, I forgot the texture on the top.
So let's go and pull that in there.
It's because I didn't scroll high enough.
There you go.
Didn't want him to feel left out.
So now let's go ahead and stack these.
And we're gonna stack these in such a way
that we can use them
and make it so that they overlay each other.
Let me show you what I mean.
Let me keep my finger on the A key.
I'm gonna add, we'll do another add.
We can do these in twos and then do one more add.
Now, if I wanted to, I could do a multiply
and I'll show you what I mean by that in just a second
and allow us to actually use a scaler
to dampen the effect.
I'm gonna grab this here, RGB,
put it into the A channel.
I'm gonna grab this RGB, put it to the B.
Same thing down here, A, B.
And then I'm gonna grab this add,
put it into the B channel,
grab this add and put it into A channel.
Now, if we wanted to, we can go straight to the output.
But if you wanted the ability to maybe dampen the effect,
we can put this into the A channel
and then create an input, function input.
In this function input, we would make a scaler.
In this particular function input,
we can set the default to 0.25,
kind of mutes things a bit.
And we can put that right into the B channel here
and then move that right into the output right there.
Now, you won't see anything like my demo
until you go and right click here
and say start preview node.
And you will see the effect that my sample one has.
There you go.
That proves that it's working for us.
Pretty great.
And again, you can choose the sorting priority.
Now, we're not done yet
because once you make a material function,
you have to expose it to library.
Click on the grid and you'll see exposed to library.
And you wanna click on that.
And I'm just gonna hit apply.
I'm not gonna hit save in this case
cause I use this class all the time for clients
and I don't need to save it.
So let's go ahead and go to that parent material
that we created.
Let's click on new caustics, call that up.
And let's go ahead and build this material.
So I'm gonna right click in here
and I'm gonna type in MF.
And what was the name?
Waves, underscore, waves.
There it goes.
And that's the one we made.
Pretty awesome.
Now we have one that's unnamed.
Oh no, that's okay.
Go into waves here and let's give it a name.
It's this guy.
So we'll call this dampening.
Not sampling, what does that mean?
So dampening, I think I spelled that correctly.
It is today.
All right.
And we got this here.
So now what we can do is one, put in some coordinates.
So we can refer to the U key
and we can still use the coordinates node here
and do a multiply.
And then, and that's why this coordinates node
is available so we can do such things.
And up there's wave coordinates right there.
He's just not on the top, that's fine.
And then we're gonna keep my finger on the S key,
left click and we'll do a UV amount
or just say tiling, that works.
And we'll set that to one.
Put that into the A channel, put this into the B channel
and put that right into wave coordinates.
Now we wanna make this material,
we wanna set up to be able to be a light function.
So we're gonna have to go in here
and we're gonna have to change that under material domain.
So let's set that with the material domain
in the details, go down to light function.
And notice all we have now is an emissive.
Let's put that emissive in there.
Now we're gonna get an error at first
because it still needs some more input.
Let me actually apply this last one we did, apply
and then we'll actually apply this.
We'll just abort that.
And you do, when you do get this error, just abort,
just wait until you get everything connected.
It's still waiting for some dependencies.
And it's like, Sean, I don't,
this doesn't make sense to me.
That's okay, we'll help you out.
So let's go and put a texture object in here.
This is gonna help to write greatly
because you can't do the effect
without actually visually seeing what it looks like.
So let's do a texture object.
There we go.
This texture object can be anything in our case.
It's like a caustic softener.
So T underscore caustics softener,
plug that right into texture.
And then we need to go into here
and looks like dampening still not quite loading
like I want.
So let's go in here.
And in this case, we'll hit save.
So let's add the node in there
or the information is what it's waiting for.
It's why we're getting the error.
And you don't really have to do dampening, but you can.
Come through the S key and we'll call this dampening.
Here we go.
It's really weird that it says dampening,
but it isn't updating dampening.
I think it's very odd.
And then we can control speed.
So let's actually do speed.
Now dampening, I'm gonna set that to what it was before
0.25.
There you go.
And that works out just great.
And speed again, can be a scaler
if you want it to be a scaler.
So we can promote that to a parameter again.
And hey, look, we got speed in here
and now it isn't moving.
So we can set that to one.
There you go.
There's the effect.
Pretty cool.
And let's see if we can apply it to our light.
I'm gonna move this over just for a second.
So again, don't let that error freak you out.
It's just Unreal wants that information
because you created it.
It needs those inputs.
So let's find this material.
There it is.
Let's hit apply.
So it updates.
Go to content drawer.
There he is.
And we're gonna go to the light
that doesn't have a light function.
Go to our content drawer and drag that right in there.
Hey, and if for some reason it doesn't show up at first
and this does happen sometimes,
what you can do is just delete the light,
recreate it and redrag it
into the light function of that light.
Pretty cool.
Here's some additional resources that you can use
and link to, to find more information
about the topics we talked about today.
Well, that's it for this class.
In the next video, we'll just do a quick recap
of what we talked about.